i don't i don't know i mean we got our  ass kicked i mean  it's just that simple um they did got to  whatever they wanted to get to in this  game and uh  you know we got to be better obviously  if we want to force a game seven so  um obviously a lot to uh learn from in  this game a lot to cover  see uh you know what we got to do better  going to game six but uh  i mean they pretty much just kicked  their ass i mean there's nothing else  really to say  yeah it scared me um  i've been talking to kyle lowry a lot he  had similar injury last year  a few other guys um i don't know  just a very uncomfortable feeling kind  of helpless  when it happened uh i didn't know i was  just looking up and  sort of happened again i didn't know  what happened with wes but after i seen  it  um i came back out on the court i told  wes you know as a  a clean play and it was just unfortunate  that uh  you know my neck you know i'm snapped  again like i did